marzouki bonjour merci d'être en direct
sur rt france alors on suit de très près
bien évidemment la situation en italie
quelle est aujourd'hui la situation au
quotidien
bonjour je lis un engouement comme il
est et dans ce sens il a dit c'est que
il y à beaucoup des gens qui sans
comptage et console et bien sûr le
problème principal en ce moment c'est
que les hôpitaux ils sont déjà beaucoup
engagé il ya pas de place ni dans les
oeufs dans le plan des recettes
au moins si l'élève est sûre les sur le
pouvoir dans la maison et danser c'est
pourquoi nous généralistes dans six mois
y aller pour voir des supports c'est bon
les gars par le quai est certainement la
personne d'un saut il y a les
départements de chansons j'aime beaucoup
crise et donc voilà on cherche de
ralentir d'infection à garder les gars à
la maison si le étant sa principale et
c'est seulement quand même besoin de ça
et de ses dps
on a pu observer une stabilisation de la
courbe des décès est ce qu'on peut
espérer une amélioration de la situation
est ce que le pic est atteint ça y est
on est en train de voilà d'être dans
cette position plutôt plane et est
stabilisé il paraît que des passeurs
gourmande
je sens le ster que 130 et peu de
problèmes ça provient ce qu'elle est les
bons les analyses de leurs statistiques
sont pas si vrai lien entre ce phénomène
en sélectionnant sur les gens qui sont à
l'hôpital ou qui arrivent donc on se
ferait au premier les nombre des
personnes engagées à la maison et donc
cette persistance de dire comment ça va
ils n'ont cette ligue anglaise de son
play est pas tous les gens qui arrivent
à l'heure
et donc il ya beaucoup groupe de quatre
qui sont dans qui on est dans sa salle
et les problèmes on espère qu'ils
seraient à descendre dans des prochains
jours je pense que les délais les avis
de pluies les plus sûrs et viable c'est
en ce qui concerne les numéros des
hospitalisés et par abonné confronté au
niveau des bassins libyen qui sort de la
voix qui les personnes qui sortent de
terre seront plus de ceux qui l'ont bien
prouvé qu'on est sur la sur la bonne
voie alors on a beaucoup
entendu à ces cv sage et ses appels à
l'aide de la part des italiens qui
visaient notamment l'union européenne on
a senti mea culpa de la part de la
présidente de cette commission
européenne ursula von der leyen qui a
souhaité s'excuser
elle a dit qu'elle allait apporter une
aide financière aux pays les plus
touchés ce que vous êtes sentis
abandonnés justement par a lieu deux
médecins enfin pour l'accès à des gens
qui sont dans la maison encore pas de
travailler dans le subsea en dix ans d
une fois fait signer un bon temps et
souffre beaucoup de ses reprises de lui
comme une mi temps et je pense que je
pense qu'on s'entend belle erreur peur
et bien sûr ses côtés semblent d'avenir
telle est la solution est meilleure avec
choi et d un os et ses jantes
sinon c'est difficile aussi penser parce
que ce serait justement la fin du coup à
la fin du confinement est évoquée par
plusieurs gouvernements européens en
italie l'ex premier ministre matteo
renzi plaide pour des tests à grande
échelle
est ce que c'est une bonne solution
justement pour prévenir pour éviter
qu'il y ait une deuxième vague de
contamination dans le pays
je pense que ce serait impossible de
déterminer si de là les confidences
temps ce sera pas possible de décréter
qu'un jour je termine à la fin des deux
du confinement est ce que c'est possible
c'est de commencer à ces absences de la
maison des parties de la fondation et
prônant la meilleure serait de faire
sans les gens qui travaillent de concert
avec ceux de l'économie d'abord et ce
serait beaucoup beaucoup ont contraint
d'avoir des tests donc pour sa vie si
ces gens qui sort qui sont ils ont déjà
eu les virus sont et peut pas l'attraper
nouveaux savoirs contre ils sont avec
cette fois explosé quand ça va aider
aussi pour l'inter à vous de jouer pour
nous d'être trahi parce que ne pas
penser que les virus tradis à être
obligés à la fin de de confinement
très bien merci beaucoup mickey mouse ok
à d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste à milan